hi everyone I'm here with the friend
David Gossett he's just submitted his
PhD in physics so I'm going to talk to
him about what it's like to maybe
finished a PhD or what it's like to do a
PhD so David what's your area of
interest
so I technically work in a field called
optical metrology which means I use
light to measure stuff so that's the
general field but what I actually work
on is signal stabilization so a lot of
things in science and Industry and
engineering require very high precision
frequency reference signal sent out and
we use an atomic clock to do that so an
atomic clock basically provides a very
high frequency high precision tick and
we send that out we use that to
synthesize other signals or make
measurements of time or frequency
distance things like that if we're doing
this over a long distance then the
transmission lines are generally fiber
optic cables they stretch and shrink a
bit you know break-ins or temperature
changes and so that means the hyper
precise tic going in one end is taking a
little bit longer a little bit shorter
time to get there and so it's not coming
out a hyper precise ticket the other
half yeah so I work on stabilizing that
so mostly I've worked on the Square
Kilometre Array telescope so the Square
Kilometre Array we're going to have
thousands of radio antennas spread over
thousands of kilometres of Australia and
South African outback and each of the
antennas needs an atomic clock signal
sent to them to synchronize the whole
array and so we need these stabilization
systems out to each of the antennas
because of the sheer distances involved
all right oh that's fascinating that
it's an inherently physics project but
it's got applications and astronomy and
seems like quite far-reaching
applications yeah so astronomy is what
we're doing with it first so this field
of signal stabilization probably goes
back about 10 years and over the past 10
years we've got to the point where we're
now using these in big science
experiments like the SK
and there'll be more science experiments
things like comparison of atomic clocks
across continents coming in the next
couple of years and within the next 10
years we'll probably move on to more
industrial applications so you might be
seeing this sort of thing coming to GPS
time education hmm no that's cool like
do you think he would driven to pick
this project by an interest in astronomy
you like those applications I was
interested in all the physics I didn't
know what I wanted to do as a PhD topic
because when I finished my undergrad I
looked at the topics on offer at my
university and other universities and I
didn't know which one I wanted to do
they all sounded sort of cool to the
same extent yeah so what I actually did
was I picked based on my supervisor I
bet I did
yeah I knew from my honors that having a
good supervisor was very important I'd
heard from others having a good
supervisor was important I've done a
summer project with my supervisor and he
was seemed really good is really good
and so I thought I'll stick with him but
that's good I had a similar thing I the
project I am working on now for my PhD I
done a summer project I'd done honours
so I knew that I liked the group and the
research I think that's just as
important if not more important than the
research itself may I think I found
group is more important I'm interested
in all the physics I'll be happy
whatever physics research I'm doing so
it's the group thanks for me cool so did
you do your bachelor's in physics say
where you came from I did in mechanical
engineering at I don't know what the
areas but when I did it you could do a
mechanical engineering and physics
double degree that they they stopped
doing that while I was going through
that degree at University of Western
Australia I originally thought I wanted
to be a mechanical engineer I liked
playing with Lego
and I like cars and planes and stuff and
Rockets so I thought I want to be a
mechanical engineer I work for SpaceX
and build rockets and I did physics out
of interest and thinking it would also
make me more employable if I have those
extra skills and over time I thought I
enjoyed the physics a lot more than the
engineering especially when I did things
like my engineering internship that I
have to do to graduate
physics is a lot more fun unlike
research I want to stay in research and
I think I want to do a PhD in physics it
sounds like your engineering skills are
useful that you you're building things
and yeah so I've had to design all sorts
of things to actually package these
things take them overseas
so yeah engineering school certainly
come in I'm a mechanical engineering
electrical engineer ring would have been
more helpful and so I think it's very
exciting that you've submitted your a
thesis is that right just recently yeah
so end of August just fresh so what what
did that feel like mixed feelings it was
it was all I've got in a day and earlier
than I predicted as I had from about the
start of the year the end of August is
my goal I was a a semi arbitrary goal
upset myself that was just when one of
my milestones was coming up with my PhD
so send me an arbitrary goal to aim for
and I didn't run over it by about a week
and a half so my new goal was to write
just submitted on Friday and it on the
first day I'd gone through the final
version of my thesis a lot but and the
final edits a lot faster and I thought
all my suit the edits from my two
supervisors I've got friends and family
to read over to find missing commas and
things I've gone through all of that it
got to lunchtime up Oh
I'm finished very thoroughly it's just
nothing
I'll go and get it printed and okay it's
printed I'll get it signed and then I'll
get it signed by the other people who
need to sign it
I've got half an hour before the
graduate research school closes I'll go
and hand this in so I've been building
building up to it and so it was exciting
my heart was thumping as I walked over
there and I was really really excited
but on the other hand it's sort of once
you've handed it and you turn or
anything I'm not sure how I feel I'm
excited to have done this a weight off
my mind but I'm still working on this
stuff I'm gonna come in tomorrow and
teach a class and work on these
experiments and come in next week I'll
try and take a bit of time off now
they'll help this thing in yeah that's
why I'm here I'm still working on this
stuff well congratulations on finishing
it that's a huge achievement now do you
feel like from the other side of a PhD
you've you've kind of just submitted
I've only just started were there a lot
of challenges getting to that point I
suppose I've learned a lot in my honours
the a lot of the research skills that
were needed the the time management
skills the research skills how to
research where to follow resources I'd
learned a lot of those in my honours so
I didn't have that learning curve so
much in my PhD I knew where to find
papers I knew who in the building I
could go and ask I've got this problem
with quantum mechanics or with wave
mechanics who's the expert in building
on that I'll go talk to them and I had
no problems with doing it was just the
technical stuff I'm in a new field how
do i clear stuff and supervisors to
learn from but I could go and read the
papers
how to do this I got to go on exchange
to various places I got sent to the
National Physical Laboratory in the UK
for two months so got to learn from
other researchers so there wasn't a
stressful learning curve though there
was no steep learning curve you have in
any PhD and I have different PhD
students treat their PhD differently and
also it depends on what you can do in
what field like a lot of PhD students
they in the lab a lot over the weekends
there in every weekend that sort of
thing yeah I tried to take a treat mine
like a nine-to-five job I will do the
occasional late night and weekend
promotional at 9:00 to 5:00 I'm working
on my PhD while watching YouTube videos
I'm not going to procrastinate yeah this
is treated like a job and that worked
well for me and I know in some things
you can't do that like if you I don't
know much about other fields I know
there are some fields where if you're
watching a vacuum chamber pump down or
certain the quantum mechanics
experiments come to temperature you need
to be there overnight to watch it down
you can't help things like that but in
which case you need to still plan that
take time off yeah I like that advice of
treating it like a nine-to-five job I
know like there's sort of a culture
within PhD students of you should be
here all the time your PhD takes over
your life and I feel like some people
almost work themselves to the ground and
that mindset like it is hard and I know
it's going to be hard but I think
managing that time you only need the
time off and even the PhD students who
are there late into the night every
night and there on the weekends when I
wanted in in the morning whether they'd
spend an hour watching youtube videos my
morning or on the weekend they might
even play games at
desk but they've been in the lab at the
University and so they haven't had the
mental shutdown that you need to relax
person I don't
certainly that wouldn't work for me I
need to go home and work on my hobbies
or sit and read a book and stop thinking
about physics for a bit yeah all right
so what are you doing now are you are
you looking for a postdoc you moving
into a postdoc work I'm moving into
postdoc work so I'm continuing what I
did for my PhD apart from the SKA I'm
also working on some free space
transmissions does that mean shooting
the lasers through the air and so now
the air is the thing per to perturbing
the laser signal and so we've got to
stabilize that so that's why I'm at Anu
today I've got some collaborators here
so I'm talking with them working to
integrate our two systems so they're
working on the steering system that will
point it through the shimmering
atmosphere while I work on them
stabilizing that laser signal so that's
what I'm working on right now that'll
take me to the end of the year I will
hopefully sign a postdoc contract in the
next couple of weeks you'd like to stay
in the academic pathway I like research
yeah I like research a lot I also like
the teaching of good yeah
just partly by accident I've got to do
quite a bit of teaching and lecturing
over the past few years and I really
enjoy that as well
it's nice to have a teaching break yeah
it gets you out of the lab for an hour
and then after that you're exhausted
because you've been teaching there god I
can get back to a lab and it's it still
work but it's a nice it's a nice mental
break yes we have a lab and I enjoy that
whole research and teaching that whole
learning process from start to finish so
that's where I want to stay in
convenience but that's that all right so
well David also does YouTube or is just
getting into it to teach some people
through that medium as well so your
channel just David G if people want to
find you for now will yes they for now I
might change that as I develop it yeah
well I'll put them late I'll put a link
in the description so you can find David
on the web and learn from what he has to
say okay thank you very much David this
is beautiful thanks for having me thanks